(letters whoosh)
- [Narrator] This
program is a presentation
of UCTV for educational
and noncommercial use only.
(mellow synth music)
- Good afternoon, my name is Ellen Gobler
and I manage the graduate
council lectures.
Thank you so much for joining us today.
It is now my pleasure to
introduce Marjorie Shapiro,
professor of physics and past chair
of the physics department.
- So I'm very pleased
to be able to introduce
to you today for his
second lecture of the week
Professor Leon Lederman, a physicist,
Nobel laureate, former
director of Fermilab,
educator and author.
I'm not gonna give you
a long biography of Leon
because his talk today
is really gonna talk
about his life and he
can tell you about it
much better than I can,
but I did wanna say that I first met him
when I went to Fermilab as
a post-doc in the 1980s,
and it says something
about Leon, first of all,
that I always called him Leon,
even though I was a peon of a post-doc
and he was the director
of Fermilab at the time.
And second of all, that I
always felt very comfortable
talking to him.
He was somebody who used to eat
in the cafeteria every day,
and if you had a question about physics,
you could just plop down next to him
and ask him a question and
he would talk for hours.
He loved talking about physics,
and he really felt
that it was an important part of Fermilab
that everyone feel that they
were part of the community.
So, as I said, the lecture
today is really going to
be about how Leon went from
his start as a physicist
through all of his great discoveries,
but as somebody who saw those
discoveries both in the past,
because some of his largest
discoveries had happened
when I was still a young student,
but also saw them come
to fruition later on,
I just wanted to make sure it was clear
to those of you who aren't
scientists in the audience
what a pivotal role he's played
in the history of our field.
The era where Leon was
doing most of his science
was an extremely important one.
It was one where we went from having
almost no understanding
of what we now believe
are the fundamental particles,
to where we have a picture, that,
although it isn't complete,
allows us a framework
for really describing what
happens on a subatomic scale,
hopefully, all the way
up to very high energies
and to what could happen
in the early universe.
And Leon played an important
role in the discovery
of several pieces of that.
The thing he won the Nobel Prize for,
the discovery of the muon neutrino,
was one of the things that told us
that matter had many copies of itself,
that there was more than one family
or generation of particles,
and then later on he showed
us the same thing was true
for the quarks as well as for the leptons,
as being the person who led the team
to discover the bottom quark.
He also played a very important role
in making sure the appropriate facilities
existed to do that science.
He was instrumental in not
only discovering the neutrino,
but in understanding how to
produce beams of neutrinos.
And when he was director of Fermilab,
he was there during the construction phase
and the initial operations
of the Tevatron,
that proton-anti-proton collider
that's been the highest energy accelerator
for the past 20 years
and will continue to be
until the turn on of the LHC,
hopefully at the end of this year.
So, which that let me welcome Leon
and I hope you all enjoy the talk.
And and the end, we will
have times for questions,
but I'll step down now.
(audience applauds)
- Are there any questions?
(audience laughs)
I hope there'll be questions.
Let me be comfortable here
and hope you all are comfortable, too.
So, I'm gonna ramble, and I hope
somewhere in this I will
talk about physics and
my experience in physics.
But let me begin with a story.
I was a graduate student
at Columbia University.
That's somewhere in New York.
And we got a telephone call
from a friend in Princeton
asking whether we would
like to meet Einstein.
And we said yes, a friend and I,
thought this was a joke.
You know, could we possibly meet Einstein?
Is that doable?
And our Princeton friend
said, oh yeah, yeah,
he goes to lunch everyday,
and if you sit on a certain bench,
I'll show you where,
he'll pass by and maybe, you know,
he'll feel like chatting with you.
So, we drove down to
Princeton and found a bench
and were told to sit here and wait for the
greatest physicist to pass by.
And sure enough, after a
little while there he came
with his research assistant, I think,
and there he was with his
baggy pants and sweatshirt
and sandals, I guess.
And as they came close to us,
we heard his assistant say,
"Would you like to meet
some students, professor?"
"Yah," he said, "Yah."
That meant yes.
So, we (coughs)
sort of jumped up, and he
stopped with my friend first,
and said, "What are you doing?"
That's German for, what are you doing?
And my friend said, "I'm doing
a thesis on quantum theory."
"Ach," said Einstein,
"you're wasting your time."
(audience laughs)
And I felt a little better,
because I'm an experimentalist,
so I was doing experiments.
I told him, I'm working on
the properties of pions.
"Ach," he said, "pions, pions.
"We don't understand the electron.
"Why do you waste time with pions?
(audience laughs)
"Okay, boys, goodbye!" he said.
And he walked off.
He had disposed of two brilliant,
handsome graduate students in 30 seconds.
(audience laughs)
but we didn't care.
We had exchanged words
with the greatest physicist of our time.
So, we were really very happy.
It was quite an experience to have that,
and I don't know if
anybody here's old enough
to have met Einstein.
Bruno, did you meet Einstein?
You see, okay.
So, I'm unique.
I've talked to Einstein. (chuckles)
It was quite an experience.
Being a graduate student, this was,
I had spent some three years helping a guy
by the name of Eisenhower
with some problem he had in Europe,
and it was called World War II. (chuckles)
And so I had, and then
as soon as I was able to
manage being discharged from the military,
I rushed to Columbia and
registered as a graduate student
and started to study physics again.
And I think that was probably
the worst year of my life,
because I had forgotten how to study
and has spent three years doing
totally irrelevant things.
And all of a sudden,
I was back to studying
and had forgotten how study.
I'd forgotten that physics was fun,
and I was having a terrible time,
and several times considered,
maybe I'm doing the wrong thing, you know,
working on trying to get an
advanced degree in physics
when I didn't really know much about it.
I'd forgotten.
And that was a very, very
hard experience for me,
and then something funny happened.
I had
been given a small room
where I could begin
to think about apparatus and think about
doing some research.
The chairman of the department
was one of the founders of
American physics, Isidor Rabi.
He had told me that this room
would be the place where
I would do some research.
I
had been away from that
room for a couple of weeks
working on preparing for a major exam,
and came back
and entered the room,
and there was a janitor mopping the floor,
and singing obviously some Italian song.
And as soon as I came in,
he sort of used his mop
as a kind of a rifle.
He held it and he announced
very loudly presumably his name.
It was Bernardini.
And I said yes, that's
very good, but be careful.
That mop is wet and the
wires there have electricity
and you're gonna cause short circuits.
And he looked at me blankly.
Didn't understand a word I was saying
his English was not so good.
But later I came out of the room
and decided to wait until the janitor
was finished with his mopping.
And Mister Rabi was actually in the hall,
and I said, "I see you have a new janitor,
"doesn't speak any English."
He said, "You mean the guy in the room?"
I said, "Yes."
"Oh," he said, "that's
not a janitor, dope.
"that's Gilberto Bernardini,
a famous cosmic ray physicist.
"And I hired him here
so that he may be able
"to get you through your PhD degree."
(audience laughs)
"Oh my god," I said.
So, I rushed back in to repair my damage
and start to communicate
with this guy, Bernardini.
And it was hard, because
his English, you know.
He used, I remember, he'd
come in in the morning
and he'd say, "Good night, everybody."
(audience laughs)
He was very friendly.
But he was very funny.
I watched him.
I realized that he was a famous scientist.
He had very curious
activities.
He would enter a room and
push the light switch,
and the lights would go on.
And he'd look at the lights and say,
(speaks foreign language)
(audience laughs)
Now, that's Italian.
And I think it means fantastic.
And then he'd turn the lights
off, turn 'em on again.
(speaks foreign language)
Turn 'em off, turn 'em on again.
He kept doing this, you know.
What, what?
Well, he seemed to think
it's just fantastic
that you can push a button
and the lights go on.
Come to think of it, it is kind of
wondrous that you push a
button and the lights go on.
And you know that you could figure out
that to push the button
and some circuit closes
and 100 miles away a motor
drives some electricity
and eventually the lights go on.
But it was, for him,
what I call a sense of wonder.
You push the button,
the lights would go on.
(speaks foreign language)
And that's what he had.
Everything he did,
he seemed to take a certain
amount of amazement.
So, we started to communicate,
and his English improved.
My Italian didn't get any better.
It was zero to begin with, it still is.
But he was
someone who took a great deal of joy.
And then the first thing he did
is he wanted to find out
what was in this laboratory,
and the thing that I showed
him that was my despair,
I built something called a cloud chamber.
What was a cloud chamber?
Well, it's a box about
12 inches in diameter,
maybe six inches deep,
and it's filled with some nitrogen gas
and some alcohol vapor of some kind.
The notion was that if
you pushed a button,
the bottom of the chamber would collapse
and the temperature of
the chamber would change,
and you were supposed to
see tracks of particles.
And all I got was white smoke.
I tried and tried, and,
you know, it was a failure.
One of my many failures
was I couldn't get this cloud chamber
to do anything but white smoke.
And Bernardini looked at the chamber,
and he says, "What's that?"
and it was a wire going into the chamber.
And I said, "That's my
radioactive source."
Gilberto said, "Take it out."
I said, "But that gives me the tracks.
"That's radioactivity."
He says, "Take it out, take it out!"
So, I took it out.
Tracks, beautiful tracks.
My radioactive source was about 10 curies
of something terrible,
ultra radioactive stuff
that was killing the chamber, so.
We learn.
What else did we?
Oh, then he showed me how to
make a kind of Geiger counter.
So, we did some machining.
He told me how to use
the tools of machinery,
and string a wire through the
middle of this copper tube,
then there was little insulators
and the wire came out,
and eventually we had
the whole thing working,
connected to an oscilloscope,
and we were watching the oscilloscope.
And all of a sudden, on the oscilloscope,
there's a sweep, and then
there was little bumps,
and Bernardini went crazy.
"It's counting!" he said, "It's counting!"
He started screaming,
and he was much shorter than I was,
and probably half my weight.
He picked me up and started
dancing around the room.
It's counting, it's counting!
This is a phenomena he must have seen
hundreds of times as a
cosmic ray scientist,
but he never got used to notion
that we were actually observing particles
that came from millions
and millions of miles away,
and came to the 10th floor
of the Pupin Physics Building
at Columbia University and
said, (speaks foreign language)!
That's what he said.
(audience laughs)
It's saying (speaks
foreign language) to us!
It was kind of, again, a
phenomenon that he must have seen
I don't know how many times,
but never
got used to it.
He had this
sense of wonder
that you can actually observe this object
that came from so far away.
And that's what he would say.
"It's come to say (speaks
foreign language) to us,
"10th floor, Pupin, Columbia University!"
It was the beginning of a
return, to me, of the fun of physics.
Because that's what it was.
For him, it was a joy,
and I kept learning from him
how to also enjoy the physics.
And little by little that was
something that restored my
enjoyment, first of all,
because he was a lot of fun.
And he put on a lot of, he
was a good actor in many ways.
And I think he was doing a
lot of this for my benefit,
but it was certainly a learning process.
I think I was very lucky
to have that experience
because I needed that kind of restoration
of enjoyment and fun.
The thing though that was most impressive
was this sense of wonder about the world.
He never got used to it.
Press a switch and the
light goes on, fantastic.
(speaks foreign language),
I should say it right.
At one point, I remember
he warned me
that sometimes, as when you're in physics,
you're going to see something
that nobody ever saw before.
He sort of warned me about the
joy of doing science and
discovering something
that no one has ever seen before.
And that was certainly a major
effect.
And so, I thought I'd tell
you this story because it's
illuminating to find out,
had it been someone else,
maybe a more conventional kind of guy,
who might have also been a good teacher,
that might have helped, too.
But having this gentleman
be so enthusiastic
and
so sharp in his enjoyment of science
was, I think, crucial to my
experience and my career.
Some years later, now at
Columbia, I was a professor.
I was doing research.
I had my own graduate students.
And what he warned me of happened.
It was three o'clock in the morning.
I don't know why these things happen
at three o'clock in the morning.
I was doing an experiment without him,
in the fields of Illinois,
and I was checking apparatus.
The graduate students hand gone to sleep,
and I was looking at the equipment,
and began to study some of the output
from one of the computers, and
it looked very funny to me.
Something unusual was happening.
And then out came what was something
we had been waiting for,
a spectacular track,
proving the existence
of muon type neutrino.
Which, nevermind what that is,
but it was something we possibly expected,
and there it was.
And all of the sudden it was,
it made you breathless.
Palms started sweating, you were nervous.
Something was happening in this apparatus
that was spectacularly beautiful
and it's implications were very deep.
It would make headlines
all over the world.
And it became hard to breathe.
I tested things, I checked.
Everything I looked at just confirmed
that at four AM
(chuckles) in a cold winter
day in the fields of Illinois,
I had good evidence of discovery.
I actually located Bernardini.
He was in fact visiting
in New York at the time,
and I had a telephone number.
And so I called him.
I told him what I had seen.
Well, by this time many years later,
his (speaks foreign
language) had disappeared
and it was Americanized.
And when I told him what I had found
out came, "Holy shit, no kidding!"
(audience laughs)
So.
That was a magical experience, certainly.
Some years later, my wife
Ellen, who's sitting out there,
and I were in Sweden.
Gilberto had come, too, to help
me receive the Nobel Prize.
Gilberto's (speaks foreign
language) was ubiquitous.
He was very excited by this.
And I said to Ellen, "Did you
ever in your wildest dreams
"imagine that we would be in Sweden,
"dining with the king and queen?"
And Ellen, very skeptical as usual,
said, "You were never
in my wildest dreams."
(audience laughs)
(laughs) That's the way it goes.
Okay, well.
What can I tell you?
Physics, the joy of doing physics
once you get to the
knack, and you're lucky.
Luck is a very important issue.
If anybody tells you, what does it take?
Luck would be probably
one of the first things
you would op for.
And, that's also the other
thing, is your surroundings.
And being at Columbia University
was a fantastic experience.
There was a sense of
vitality to the thing.
Times were appropriate.
Discoveries were on the horizon,
and new apparatus was available.
If I compare those lucky times
to the poorer opportunities we have today,
certainly because of
the economic crisis
and the difficulties of
pursuing experiments at high cost
and complicated
apparatus and so on,
we were very lucky in those days.
The big problem today is to
try to maintain, restore,
and improve the opportunities
for young people
to have the kind of experiences I had
in my graduate school days at Columbia.
What else can I tell you?
A major thing, I do want
to say a few things about
opportunities.
One of the things that I got interested in
and talked a lot about
yesterday was science education.
But what I didn't talk about is
a school
that I had the good luck and
maybe a little bit of wisdom
in starting in Illinois.
It's called the Illinois
Math and Science Academy.
As a director of the Fermi Laboratory,
I was interested in
students and in education,
and we had a lot of
opportunities to invite students
to come into the laboratory.
And they could take courses.
There was Saturday
morning physics courses,
and out of that a
procession of young students
that would come into the laboratory.
And that inspired me because I realized
that the average schools,
in
Chicago area and Illinois,
were not exceptionally
good at teaching young people.
And so I got involved in
this thing and organized
something called the Illinois
Math and Science Academy,
abbreviated IMSA, I-M-S-A.
It was a special school.
I had to see the governor of Illinois.
This was one of these governors
who happens not to be in jail.
(audience laughs)
It's unusual for Illinois,
but this was an okay governor.
And he was intrigued by the notion
of creating a special school in Illinois.
I told him about the, I mean,
he knew about the famous
Bronx High School of Science,
and I said, we need a Bronx
High School of Science
out here on the prairie of Illinois.
He authorized the existence
of a special school
for gifted young people
in which the school itself
would also be a place
where students could live in.
It was a residential public school
that would carry students
through the last three
years of high school.
And that opened in 1986,
and first graduating class was in 1989.
So, it's a little over 20 years now
producing some of the most brilliant
students.
These were all restricted
to the state of Illinois by the law,
but it was a fantastic experience,
especially since in the last month or two
the INTEL foundation, which,
INTEL is a huge electronics company
and they
spend a lot of money education,
on science education.
They organized
a study of schools.
And we were very happy
to learn not too long ago
that the Illinois Math Science Academy
was given what's called an
INTEL Star Innovator award
as the best science high
school in the nation.
They had tested some 700 schools
for us to win this particular award,
which was certainly gratifying.
Some of our graduates by now have had
huge careers
in science, but not only in
science, but all subjects.
But the notion of
giftedness and taking care of this
idea that young students who have a gift
should be encouraged in
the best possible way
was something that I believed
in and still believe in.
And the Illinois Math Science
Academy is a fantastic school.
If you're ever discouraged
or feel
that you need to cheer up or so on,
I invite you to come and visit the school.
It's about 30 miles west of Chicago,
very close to the Fermilab,
which you're also invited to visit
but the school itself has this
fantastic group of students
that are increasingly making
their way in the world.
Of course, this is a high school,
but the
push they get towards higher education
is enormous and gratifying.
And every time I feel I
need more encouragement,
I go to the school, and I sit
and chat with the students.
We now have 4,000 graduates
that will graduate.
Something like
200 or 300 students a year.
They go to universities everywhere.
I'm sure there are many of our
students here at California.
But to take special care of giftedness
is an important thing.
It's not the only thing you
want to do in education,
but it is an important issue
because these are the students
that will become the doctors
and the
wise people that will
sustain our society in times to come.
Illinois Math Science Academy
has projects, and one
of the projects we had
was for each of these students
to pick a famous scientist
and write a biography of the scientist.
Now, it's interesting that
when you challenge them
to name a famous scientist,
and I say, nobody present company.
Just pick the name of a famous scientist.
And they were silent.
They didn't know any names of scientists.
So, I said, okay,
well, you have subjects you like.
Look up the subject and find a scientist
that is active in that subject.
And eventually they did.
That was one of our interesting projects,
because they then,
there were 15 students and
they picked 15 scientists,
and I told,
they then did research on
what the scientist had done.
At some point, I said, you have
to interview the scientist.
Well, how do we do that?
So, I called up a lady by
the name of Claudia Dreifus
who writes for the New York Times
and she writes an article periodically,
a biography of some living scientist.
So, she came and very kindly
gave these kids a lecture
on how you interview a scientist.
What do you ask?
How do you ask questions?
How do you keep the conversation going?
And as a net result,
each of these students
wrote an essay.
I warned the scientist that they picked,
the ones I could reach on the telephone.
You may get a funny telephone call
from a high school student.
Please be kind, he's
gonna write a biography.
And eventually, (chuckles)
that's what happened.
They wrote biographies
and I put them together
and called a publisher I knew.
And he said oh, he'd be delighted.
So, there's a book called
Structure of, oh, I
forgot the exact title.
But it had to do with
famous American scientist.
And each of these kids is
now an author of a book.
The book has these delightful
stories of the scientists.
The kids emphasized, of course,
the high school experience
of the famous scientists.
I think you must know some of them here.
Charlie Townes is in the book.
And these students wrote
a really lively story of these scientists.
That was one of the
projects these students had.
So, again,
I wouldn't mind answering any questions
or listening to better stories
on experiences of various kinds.
- [Audience Member] Einstein
has say that David Bohm,
David Bohm is his intellectual successor.
- Yes.
- [Audience Member] So, what do you think
about David Bohm's quantum theory?
- (laughs) David Bohm.
Well, uh.
He's a very interesting guy, but I don't,
I mean, I think if you want
to learn quantum theory,
there are probably
better
educational books on quantum theory now.
And he is, I think his book is rather old,
and I don't remember,
I can't really tell you if it
was one of the better books.
But by now you can find
some really good quantum
mechanics books available
that are more modern, more up to date.
David Bohm was an interesting guy.
But that's a complicated story
of his problems and so on.
I think he was,
actually, when he was
real political troubles,
many of us were very sympathetic
to his point of view.
- [Audience Member] Hi, I'm Sherry Shee
from The Exploratorium,
a museum in San Francisco
that was founded by Frank
Oppenheimer back in 1969.
And I was wondering,
did you visit museums when you were a kid,
and did you know the Oppenheimer brothers,
and if you can tell us
some stories about that?
- (chuckles) Museums, yes.
I always lived in New York City,
and we had a plethora of museums,
and I liked to go to museums,
especially the Museum of Science
and Industry in Manhattan.
I certainly went to the museums.
Now, you asked about Oppenheimer.
I knew both Frank
Oppenheimer and, what's the,
(chuckles) Robert Oppenheimer.
That was part of our life.
It was a political problem.
The story of Oppenheimer
is well documented.
There are several books on the subject.
He was, of course, a heroic
figure in World War II
having led the research which
led to the nuclear bomb.
Then he was, I think, dumped on by,
because he was
a free thinker and,
although he made a huge contribution
to the war effort in World War II,
he was unpopular in the military
and they eventually, for reasons
which are very complicated,
his efforts
to help the United States
were thwarted by people
who felt politically he was
not correct enough for them,
so he retired to Princeton
where he was director for the
Institute for Advanced Study.
But his scientific
career was sort of ended
by a dramatic experience
he had politically.
- [Audience Member] Leon, I'd
wondered whether you'd talk
just a little bit about your experiences
in the end of 1956
when violation of parody was discovered.
- Ah, '56, parody, parody, yes.
I'm gonna (chuckles) try
to remember what happened.
I'm really,
drawing a kind of blank as
to the sequence of events
which led to--
- [Audience Member] Let
me ask more specifically,
when did you hear about
Madame Wu's result,
and when did you start
doing experiments yourself?
- Thank you.
- What did you know
about other people who were
racing to get the results
at the same time?
- We had the benefit at Columbia
of having Tsung-Dao Lee,
who was a professor of
physics at Columbia,
and he was one of the authors
along with Frank Yank of the notion
that one of the
basic laws of physics,
which we all believe in,
conservation of parody,
might not be actually a valid
idea.
And there was evidence,
if I remember right,
from various experiments
to indicate that perhaps
one of these basic, sacred laws of physics
we all thought was certainly valid
might in fact
not be valid.
And they gave us, they actually proposed
a series of experiments
that might test the
validity of this notion.
One of the dramatic consequence of this
has to do with mirror symmetry,
that if you look in a mirror,
let's say one wall of
this room is a mirror,
and all you guys are doing experiments,
and the guys in the mirror
are of course doing the same experiments,
the question is,
is the symmetry such that
both the mirror experimentalists
and the real experimentalists
get the same results?
And 99% of physicists or more would say,
"Of course, they must get the same results
"because that's just the mirror image
"of what's going on here."
But much to everybody's surprise
and to the wisdom of Lee and Yang,
they
decided that perhaps the
symmetry was not perfect,
that there was violation
of mirror symmetry,
and that the mirror world
was not precisely the same as our world.
And they made that part of their
paper
which gave rise to the notion of,
well, can we check this experimentally?
And of course the story was
that when experimenters,
now full of doubt about the
validity of mirror symmetry
and went at it and made tests,
we found out that the symmetry
between the world and the
mirror world was not perfect.
That was a major discovery,
because for 50 years or so,
people believed that the mirror world
and the real world were identical.
How can it be different?
But it turned out that it was known
as the mirror symmetry was broken.
It was not a correct symmetry,
and that made a big
change in our philosophy
of how particles behave.
That was very exciting.
Every once in a while
you get epochs of great
excitement in physics
where you're rushing to do an experiment
and you're not sure you know
what the results will be.
And it's the greatest joy
when in fact it turns out
that the kind of results you expected
don't turn out to be the correct results
but something totally
different takes place.
And that's what happened
during the parody days.
We discovered by careful experiments
that the mirror world and the real world
are actually different.
There are differences.
And that was a period of great excitement.
Now, we're used to it and we understand
the violation of mirror symmetry.
Yeah?
- [Audience Member] Professor Lederman,
do you remember, what were you doing--
- Make a little space
between you and microphone.
- [Audience Member] What were you doing
when the Nobel Prize committee
notify that you have one the Nobel Prize?
And what's your first,
what's your feeling,
when the first time?
- Let me say, winning the Nobel Prize
is something I recommend very highly.
(audience laughs)
It really is a lot of fun.
This,
probably as usual, it
happens late at night.
You get a telephone call.
I think in this particular
case or one very much like it,
my wife had the phone
and we sort of suspected
there would be an award.
It was rumored and so on.
And she got the telephone
call and she said to me,
"We can't go to Sweden
"because I have a dinner date that night."
(audience laughs)
And she handed me the phone.
And she was kidding, of course. (laughs)
So, I recommend winning
a prize very highly.
It's a great thing to do.
- [Audience Member] I
was actually a student
of yours at Columbia.
- You were?
- Yes.
- Oh, yeah, you sat in the third row.
- [Audience Member] You gave me an A-plus
in physics in 19-- (laughs)
And was an undergraduate
and graduate student
during most of those yeah.
I got my PhD with Charlie Townes.
It was amazing to me, and
people have remarked on that,
that almost every professor I
had who won the Nobel Prize,
and I was wondering if you
had, when you were there,
had a sense of this being
some sort of golden age,
the other people being--
(Leon laughs)
- Well, as a graduate student at Columbia,
we had a button made
which we wore occasionally called Not Yet.
(audience laughs)
And that's because
the faculty at Columbia were
loaded with Nobel Prizes.
There was Rabi, there was Townes.
There was Willis Lamb.
It was just this star-studded faculty.
So, the graduate students would, you know,
feel a little bit awkward about this,
so we got this nice button
that said Not Yet, which
(audience laughs)
was a sense of wild optimism (laughs)
that something good would happen to you.
- [Audience Member] I
think, two experiences.
First of all, I had a lab on
the 10th floor of Pupin, also.
- Oh, yeah.
- [Audience Member] But
I remember one morning,
doing experiments, staying up at night
and coming down the elevator,
and I was in the elevator with
Lee and Kusch and Rabi, actually.
- Three Nobel laureates.
- [Audience Member] Yeah, I could resist.
The only time I had that much chutzpah.
I couldn't resist saying,
"Do you guys realize I'm the
only person in this elevator
"who doesn't have a Nobel Prize?"
(audience laughs)
Gutsy thing for a graduate student to say.
- Well, it was a great department
and having those people around was
a fantastic experience.
And even somewhat lesser creatures
like the Bernardini story
who would always say
(speaks foreign language)!
What you learned there was a
sense of wonder in physics,
that you learn something,
and it's just beautiful.
That, in fact, was a comment made to me
some time ago by my senator in Illinois,
who's now the president
of the United States.
We had a conversation on physics.
He seemed to know a lot about it.
And what he said to me was amazing to me.
He said, the thing about
science, and especially physics,
he says, is when you
guys make a discovery,
it turns out to be beautiful.
Now, that was a surprise,
because to say something
in physics is beautiful
is something that
physicists say all the time,
but not when outsiders
are listening, you know?
You don't want to be bragging (laughs)
about the fact that the
subject was beautiful.
But here was a layperson, in a sense,
who recognized the beauty of science.
So, I'm very happy about
having him in the White House
to care, hopefully at some point
supporting the increases
that he really understands
we need in research
and education, which is
what we're all devoted to.
- [Audience Member] I
have to say, I remember,
among all the professors, that
you really communicated that.
I think this was the,
I don't know there was some sort of
honors physics for smart freshman and--
(audience laughs)
Like sophomores.
And I think the last semester
was optics and atomic
physics or something.
(Leon laughs)
Maybe that was the most beautiful
of the subjects, I don't know.
- Right.
There's a guy behind you.
He's bigger, and I would
get out of his way.
(Leon laughs)
(audience members laugh)
- [Audience Member] Professor, what
in current physics research
do you find particularly exciting?
- Now?
- Yes.
- Oh, gosh.
Well, I think it's very clear
to me that what, there's,
we're in an epoch, I think,
of incredible discovery.
You can take a deep breath
and sort of sense discovery in the air.
Part of this discovery
comes from astrophysics.
You know, there's a new subject
called particle astrophysics.
Particles are the smallest thing
we know about in our world,
and the astrophysics are the large things
that have to do with
galaxies and stars and so on.
These two subjects are sort
of joined by phenomenon
that bridge both subjects.
So, this is a very exciting time
and what will cap the excitement
will be the new machine
that's under construction,
hopefully will start working
within the next months
in Switzerland in Geneva.
The large hadron collider, it's called.
That's going to
be like a new telescope, you know.
Galileo, you know,
made a telescope and looked up
and discovered the moons of
Jupiter and so many things,
in fact, started scientific astronomy,
and this new machine that's
under construction in Europe,
which is now participating,
so all the major nations
are participating in this,
will certainly give us new phenomenon
and will help us understand
many of the puzzles
that are bothering us right now
that have to do with astrophysics
and dark energy and
dark matter phenomenon.
We're in an exciting time.
I wish that economically we would
overcome our present difficulties
and begin to really
accelerate the kind of research
that will reveal what's going on.
Yeah.
- [Audience Member] Leon,
when you were a kid,
was there some experience or--
- I'm still a kid!
(audience laughs)
- That's right.
But that started you down the path
to become a physicist instead
of, say, a Wall Street wizard?
- I tried Wall Street! (laughs)
I didn't work.
Why did I get into physics?
Actually, in the beginning,
in high school and early college,
I was a chemistry major.
But little by little I turned to physics
because chemistry was complicated
and physics was simple.
(chuckles) So I thought.
And
the physicists in the area
were more dynamic, if you like,
and physics had a great attraction
because in some ways, it was very simple.
You dealt with a particle,
two particles, and so on.
Chemistry was very complicated.
There are all kinds of molecules
sticking out in all directions,
so I thought physics had a kind of appeal
because ultimately it
looked for the simplicity
and try to make the most
of understanding the
world that we live in.
So, I think that was, for
me, a very good choice,
is to stay with physics.
Now, some of my best friends
talk to chemists. (laughs)
- [Audience Member] When you think back
to the history of mankind,
can you mention two or three inventions
that were most beneficial?
- Inventions?
Well, inventions sort of
implies something that's useful
like, I don't know, automobile invention.
That's a good question.
If I can think of discoveries, I think,
that's a better word than inventions.
And clearly,
the fact that we can
understand so much of the world
in which we live is already a discovery.
I think that's important to know.
We can understand, we can predict
Haley's comet will appear 2061
at three o'clock in the
afternoon on Thursday,
and pretty much we can get it right.
So, we know a lot about
the world in which we live.
But there are a lot of things
about the world in which we
live that we don't understand,
and the challenge of understanding those
is very great and important.
We have lots of problems facing us,
environmental problems and social problems
and economic problems.
But understanding the world, I think,
and understanding the
world in which we live
in a thorough and deep way
is one of the major tasks we have.
And this is something mankind
has been concerned with
for a long time, and it's still there,
that we do have so many things
that we need to understand
better than we do now.
- Okay, with that I'd like
to thank Leon for his talk
and thank all of you for coming.
(audience applauds)
(gentle synth music)